taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them like folks Joe to Rosa here
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds
why am I doing the channel alone
well sometimes I do it alone because
Sal's not here and the guest doesn't
know it and sometimes I do it alone
because of this
the time keeps changing so it's just
it'd be done by 12 30 but there's no way
I just pushed I push Ian to one so
um
what's your
uh we I just looked at it and I'm like
we're not going to make it so we we were
like let's just start heading up towards
our studio because we're gonna Bank some
podcasts of our own today
that's cool if you guys could my day up
anymore I'd appreciate it
Jesus Christ no no
it's already 12 30 and I looking at this
thing on the on the waves it keeps
getting pushed back and pushed back
because what's the way you say now
well then I changed the address we just
made the call to we're like well [ __ ] it
there's no way we're going to make it so
let's just head up to to our studio
all right all right all right
um okay
uh dude I'm super sorry I I didn't I
didn't realize you had a second thing
and I dude I I I really didn't know we
were getting out of that gym and Sam I
was there at nine o'clock and I didn't
know I was going to be on for
for two hours normally when they have me
on it's like 20 minutes
let me try to move this stuff back up
yeah dude I I am Superstar are you out
and about tonight are you
laying low yeah
yeah all right man
talk to you guys all right buddy sorry
love you
that's [ __ ] day word they didn't
feel like coming down yeah because they
wanted to go record and I'm [ __ ]
pissed uh yeah what do you want to do
[ __ ] furious right now I don't know
we just lost the whole [ __ ] episode
so there you have it folks our guests
today have canceled who were those
guests one Steve Byrne
and one Joe Gatto
they were supposed to be here
I love the way they canceled on you in
from a car
from a Lincoln Town Car they call and
they cancel saying that the tree
lighting ceremony has made Midtown
completely cut off what what what is
this a Seinfeld episode sounds like one
of their jokes man it's one of those
impractical jokes I know yeah am I being
am I being impractically joked right now
did they ever have term on their show
they needed a term like punked it was
never you know no they never had a punch
I just got out
sure did we just got you got deep down
we got burned that's a good one sick
burned sick burned I came here while you
were showering to set this up and then
they canceled on you
so anyway folks
I'm doing the episode do you think they
were ever in the car by the way when
they do you think the car ever existed I
don't think I don't think Steve Byrne
and Joe got to wherever in the car I
don't think they were ever I think they
were in their Studio Uptown to record
their podcast the entire time
I don't even think they're in Manhattan
I I think they're out wherever the hell
they live I should see if they were
really on Jim and Sam let me see
yes they claimed that they were on Jim
and Sam
shout out shout outs to Jim and Sam uh I
love Jim and Sam they're what but did I
I didn't [ __ ] on Jim and Sam at all did
I no to Steve no if I did it wasn't
[ __ ] on Jim and Sam I was just
making I was just giving Steve Greece at
one point you said no one's ever stood
me up for Sam Roberts well that is true
that is true nobody has ever stood me up
for Sam Roberts before
uh but yeah no uh I am it's confirmed
they were on uh Jim and Sam so they
didn't lie about that which by the way
Jim and Sam ends at at 11 11. and then
they're like we just at 11 50 see we
don't have the first call on tape no we
only have the second call on tape the
first call was
they said
that they were on Jim and Sam and they
just got done that was at 11 17. you
didn't just get done you stood around
talking for for another 17 minutes that
show ends I've done jimin so many times
I've done many serious shows they are
that has to end on the nose
so you say I have to go now I have
another thing to get to
because I'm promoting
the reason we're going to have Steve
here the reason Steve called me 8
000 times to be on the podcast was to
promote his new special that's why
did you uh watch any of his special I
haven't watched it yet and now I never
will
[Laughter]
but he called me eight thousand times to
to because he was he was coming to New
York to do press to
and I said Steve we got it let's do it
wanna and better yet let's have you and
Joe on you guys promote your podcast too
not only did they blow you off they
still got their plug well I didn't plug
the podcast and I didn't say the name of
Steve special uh uh
then we move we start today people
people we start today
pimp shows up at 9 45 a.m because godo
says he's got to do it at 11 A.M or it's
a no-go we start the whole recording day
I move the other guests around them
now we got guests coming we got this oh
yeah yeah folks Joe DeRosa here and I am
coming to you live starting this week
I'm going to be in St Petersburg Florida
where a coastal creative doing we'll see
you in hell live this coming Thursday
with my buddy Pat Walsh and I believe a
special guest is going to be there also
on the 9th and 10th I'm doing my show I
Never Promised You a Rose Garden also a
coastal creative on December 14th
hitting New York New York the crane
theater once again I Never Promised You
a Rose Garden bringing the show down to
Austin Texas January 13th and 14th at
the Vulcan and then New York again
Levittown New York at Governors January
20th and 21st come and check out all
these shows more being added all the
time stay tuned get all your Show
tickets and all your show info
joeinfo.com also please check out we'll
see you in hell my movie podcast with
Pat Walsh we are over at we'll see uh
I'm sorry we're at patreon.com
wsiyhpodcast
asked you can get all the new episodes
there and the back catalog is available
online wherever you get your podcasts
and finally Joey roses my barn sandwich
shop is now open seven days a week at 11
30 a.m every day drinks and sandwiches
all day long come through thank you for
the support we've turned a year old I
can't believe we made it this is amazing
thank you guys we couldn't have done it
without you come see us and if you want
info about the barn sandwich shop
joeyrosesnyc.com thank you anyway pimp
and I are here why because the taste
buds ship does not sink folks it keeps
going no matter what this is like in
private parts did you ever see private
parts yeah of course classic yeah this
is like when like it keeps it keeps
dwindling down everybody keeps getting
fired we're leaving the show and then
it's finally Stern just in that room by
himself reading the news and then like
reacting to what he's reading this is
what this is this is like at this point
there it's almost a manic episode which
means we're gonna come back and we're
gonna be stronger than ever we're gonna
be stronger than ever uh today we're
going to talk about carrots
versus I mean we don't have to
cauliflower I mean why not I mean you
got excited about we had a couple topics
well actually the poll went out the
poll's out actually yeah so let's just
do it carrots versus sunflower I love it
um I uh I I
I actually do feel quite strongly about
this and I'm upset that this battle
isn't happening what side are you on the
guys that took it carrots your carrots
okay I could see you as a root vegetable
guy I'm team carrots uh Gatto and Steve
were team cauliflower
which
you know I've never imagined cauliflower
entering jogato
the uh
well he looks fairly in shape no sort of
I don't know I've got dad bod but I
looked at a shape I don't know
yeah I've seen him with his shirt off
he's got a gut he's got that like he's
funny man he's funny as hell he's got
funny body it's like hilarious he's got
funny body yeah where like the belly
comes out he's got like old man Italian
belly where it's fun yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah not just despicable but
he looks like he he he he he he looks
like a guy that that enjoys a meal
but he doesn't look what I'm getting at
is he doesn't look like a junk food guy
he just looks like a hearty that's fair
he's heartily guy
Steve's in pretty good shape from what I
remember I just he always has a raincoat
on
yeah or a suit you're starting a suit
were you ever on his show didn't he have
a TBS show
I was I was on it once it was it was
nice of one of my best friends to give
me one line
I can't even imagine I don't want to
talk about it oh no
party at Joey roses that went good oh
well that was Black Friday shout outs to
all the supporters
that came out to the Joey Rose's party
on
uh uh new uh on Black Friday
um almost said New Year's Eve uh on
Black Friday shout outs to all of you
thank you uh we had a rousing uh affair
on Black Friday to celebrate commemorate
I mean are you ready for this pimp one
year
we hit one year it flew by too you know
goodbye man one year which is insane uh
I almost feel like today
instead of battling carrots and
cauliflower because we feel like we have
to because we lost our guests and we put
the pull up I feel like we could almost
do a taste bud say about the what the
last year of running a food
establishment that's been like yeah
please yeah yeah let's do it we can save
the battle whatever we could save the
battle yeah I don't think anybody's
gonna be mad that you and I aren't fake
I would love to hear your your
evaluation of cauliflower well I also
but I'll save it for when we do it
because here's the thing
here's the thing we could absolutely
that's a battle that all we need to do
is find somebody that's passionate about
cauliflower
and then I want to save everything I
would say about cauliflower cauliflower
is one of the few that I'll say this
much now to tease it yes I am team
carrot
and cauliflower is one of the few
vegetables that in my older age avoid at
all costs at this point
interesting well they made it hip again
they serve it with like yeah parmesan
cheese yeah yeah no I love that people
that don't eat meat
think it's like a healthy way to eat
wings
[Laughter]
gosh it's healthy
all right the health crazes yeah uh
anyway uh we'll we'll get to it but my
point is is uh
I don't know or should we just do it
right now no I don't care I'm just gonna
bring up some stuff I had just thought
was interesting I'll run it by we could
just do a podcast we don't have to argue
look we could do the first ever I'm
battling
I'll do I'll do the whole battle myself
I'll do the whole battle myself fighting
himself yeah I'll do you and you chime
in wherever you feel yeah
yeah let's go let's go Joe fights Joe
I mean I know what team I'm on
I like it it's a manic this is a manic
episode we might as well I do this one
most nights on this couch by myself
right is that what happened the lot of
debates happen but right here alone with
just me what was the last uh lonely
debate that happened uh it happened
after Thanksgiving dinner uh when I got
home
oh no yeah you got me interested I
replayed a lot in my head as I sat here
alone drinking whiskey
it was a hell of a night oh I painted
something new you want to see my new
paintings yeah you want me to pass it
yeah I don't know if I'm gonna add
anything to this yet but this is my
latest thing that I'm working on
I actually think this is pretty cool
this is my latest uh it's a where are we
at here
is my camera so yeah it's a silver face
I like it with like pink clouding over
it
and I don't know if I'm going to add
anything to it I think it needs
something I can't put my finger on it
but like it needs something but maybe it
doesn't I don't know that's kind of
interesting if that's just on your wall
like that definitely feels very
Chinatown you know what does that mean
s it just looks like art that would be
nothing against Chinatown but that
sounded like an insult oh no I just yeah
just because we're in the vicinity of so
okay
yeah it's
I mean I don't know maybe it needs to I
don't know but anyway I dig it it's
trippy you just throw it on the table I
was gonna write on it
I was gonna because I like sometimes
doing these when I put text or something
that's cool yeah I was gonna write on
this well I don't want to tell you what
I was going to write on it I might just
do it anyway okay
with all these I don't know I just am
finding it incredibly cathartic
to paint and to create art on different
cameras I'm dying to do an art gallery
with all the fan art maybe there'll be a
DeRosa section dude I've got like I'm
not kidding I've got about
eight or ten pieces in that red thing
over there that chest
uh and then I've got a few on my walls
that I'm that I'm that I hung up along
that I did a long time ago that I'm
proud of and um I'd be I'd happily put
up that'd be cool
yeah
you see what people think yes Consulting
tickets
let's do it
all right folks the no pressure art show
um
coming soon to a deli near you by the
way you saw the new uh Mario trailer
with Chris Pratt as Mario yes it's
despicable
I I we've talked at length about this
song we'll see you in hell okay
so I don't have much more to say about
it but
you know the bullet points are I think
it's crazy that they didn't get the
original you know the guy that's made
the Mario voice famous to be Mario
that said
I also can't stand that Mario voice so I
don't I I was always a bigger fan of
like Brooklyn Mario then like
you know and all that
um
but at the same time it's like as dumb
as I think this
this collection of people is like like
this star-studded affair of Super Mario
Brothers is I do think the movie
actually looks good and like and I do
think it's funny that John languizamo
was complaining about the lack of
diversity because I was just like is
this where we're looking to to lead us
the Super Mario Brothers movie come on
guys
anyway yeah that was really stupid those
are all my takes but uh but I did want
to run this by you too uh there's a new
thing called dump dinners have you seen
it here I'm gonna pass this to you have
you seen this no
it's where a family actually dumps they
have like a disposable tablecloth and
they dump the food right on the table
and it's supposed to be some kind of new
diet thing
it's not a diet thing it's people
that are so [ __ ] lazy
and think that they have to do anything
to make their children eat
it's it's it's common this is a common
problem parents have with children
getting the kid to eat
kids don't want to eat a lot of the time
because they don't want what it is
you're sure people do this without kids
kids just happen to be in this video
it's it's over people it's over
but you know what I mean like like when
I was a kid if I didn't want to eat
dinner it was like okay you're gonna sit
here until you eat dinner and then you
don't get to watch TV you don't get to
do any of these things
you sit here until you eat dinner you
have to eat dinner and you have to eat
the dinner we're serving you because
that's the balanced meal we're providing
you too bad you want McDonald's tonight
you can't have it you have to eat
the salad and the fish or whatever the
hell it was and
it's like insane to me man like people
are like oh I just don't know what to do
with my kid like I try to get it and
then what we do is we'll let them so
then people let their kids bring their
phone to the table and then their iPads
at the table and then they're this and
it's like
for Christ shakes people stop trying to
be friends with your kids discipline
your kids you're not a tyrant for making
your child eat dinner
and you're not cool for dumping [ __ ] all
over the table I mean look I get it once
in a while if it's like a fun we're
gonna do it's Friday we're gonna do fun
dump day I get that but I have a feeling
that's not what this is I have a feeling
this is a a Tuesday night in this house
history
I mean it's like those seafood places do
it I guess it's sort of similar
but at least the seafood places it's
it's sort of like
you know it's like contained food as
they sometimes call it like
to me it's different to like go to a
Shiva place and and pull a CL a clam
that is a shell on it whatever out of a
bake thing that they don't then like
what that person is doing where it's
like there was like powder and dust and
right whatever the [ __ ] that was like
pasta with Parmesan cheese like right
now yeah on your table if we put a
tablecloth and you dumped a thing of
pasta and sauce disgusting and ate off
the table so that's my point is like
it's like you're putting your fingers
into other [ __ ] people putting their
fingers to do at least with a with a
clambake or something you're touching a
part that you don't eat you're you know
it's a vehicle there's a vehicle or even
like the corn cobs in it or whatever
or even the potato you're grabbing a
potato people don't have their fingers
in that potato in theory you dump pasta
on the table people are putting their
fingers into what you're grabbing it's
disgusting it's [ __ ] disgusting
people are disgusting
I I I I you can't
Pat Walsh always says you can't leave
the house and he's right you can't leave
the house anymore I can't I can't look
at anything anymore
it just makes me sick I just watch the
news now and it's you don't even know
what to do with yourself everything's
just killing you
get your farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door how with
hello fresh you're skipping the trips to
the grocery store because you can count
on hellofresh to make home cooking easy
fun and affordable
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit especially now during the
holidays all right we're right in the
thick of it and it's a busy time of year
and it's easier than ever to create
those Chef crafted recipes and
pre-portioned ingredient we're using
pre-portioned ingredients why because
it's all delivered right to your door
again from hellofresh you don't have to
spend time prepping and planting and all
that stuff you don't have the time it's
the holidays get to the cooking in the
eating uh you need dinner in a hurry of
course you do it's the holidays
hellofresh is quick and easy options
like 20 minute meals and easy cleanup
recipes allow you to do so so you can
enjoy your good time around the dinner
table with the loved ones and less time
in the kitchen over 35 weekly recipes
there's something to please everyone
you can also easily customize which I
like you can customize recipes you can
swap out protein swap outside there's
over 35 weekly recipes there's something
here for everybody and you can easily
customize your recipes by swapping up
proteins or sides I really like that so
it makes it though if you have a certain
dietary restriction or preference you
can this is accommodating for you uh
hellofresh is great so go to
hellofresh.com tastebuds65 and use promo
code taste buds six five for 65 percent
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com tastebuds six five and
use code
tastebuds65 for 65 percent off plus free
shipping
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
folks winter is here and I want to talk
miracle miracle why do I want to talk
Miracle because here's the thing when it
comes to sleeping
the right temperature is key that's the
most important thing for me I have
struggled with it in the past I have
been too hot too cold to this to that
can't stand it hurts my night of sleep
makes me groggy and Grumpy in the
morning and Miracle has created an
amazing silver infused type of bed sheet
with uh that was inspired by NASA that
allows a perfect temperature to be
maintained all night long did you know
that the temperature
at night Ken have one of the greatest
effects on your sleep because here's
what I ask I know I said it affects me I
didn't know that I didn't know that
until somebody explained it to me and
you'd think it'd be obvious but it's not
necessarily obvious that's why Miracle
is great trust me you think you're
having a hard time sleeping it might
have something to do with temperature
all right traditional bed seats sheets
also can Harbor more bacteria than a
toilet seat that's disgusting that can
lead to acne that can lead to allergies
that can lead to stuffy noses it's just
gross Miracle brand offers a whole line
of self-cleaning eco-friendly bedding
such as sheets and it doesn't stop there
there's pillowcases there's comforters
and these prevent 99 of bacteria and
require three times less laundry that's
the other thing I don't have laundry in
my apartment or my building I have to go
to a laundromat I don't want to go often
and I want my sheets to stay clean this
helps and also you're gonna if you have
a laundry in your house you can save a
lot of water and all that stuff all
right
Again self-cooling Properties for a
better quality sleep with the silver
infused Fabrics originally developed by
NASA self-cleaning luxurious also
comfortable quality stuff here and they
make a great gift so enough you're going
to try a miracle by going to try
miracle.com tastebuds again try
miracle.com tastebuds and today
here's what you're gonna get special
deal our listeners save 40 off and be
sure to use that promo code taste buds
at checkout to save even more
and get three free towels
Miracles so confident in their product
it's backed by a 30-day money-back
guarantee so if you aren't 100 satisfied
you'll get a full refund upgrade your
sleep with Miracle brand go to try
miracle.com tastebuds and use the code
taste buds to claim your three piece
towel set for free plus you're going to
save 40 off again that's try miracle.com
tastebuds treat yourself or a friend or
a loved one this holiday season thank
you miraclebrand for sponsoring this
episode
like now they're saying plant-based diet
can cut bowel cancer risk by 20 do you
think that's worth the trade-off
well I I think a plant-based diet is
good
I would never argue that it's a bad
thing to do but uh you know can it cut
bowel cancer by 20 I don't know
who the hell no I don't think it's worth
I love me and I couldn't do plant-based
to 20 it's not there's keto people that
would say the opposite of that bowel
cancer claim there's there's paleo
people that would say the opposite of
that well you know it's it's funny how
diet and religion are kind of the same
who whatever God you believe in is God
yeah exactly what are you gonna do dude
what are you gonna do people that never
smoke a cigarette in their life get lung
cancer it happens it's like it's it's
you got to live you gotta have a good
time
you know you pick your spots you don't
want to you know like I'm not saying go
out there and eat you know a Whopper
with cheese every day for lunch because
you only live once like have balance in
your life you know but have a good time
man that's it that's it that's all you
can do it's like that's it you know
don't take it so serious you know uh
it's it's by the way let's talk some
foods like while we're on the topic of
food on this food podcast or the
primarily based food podcast
uh you know what I had it Thanksgiving
Day the one highlight of my Thanksgiving
Day
oh no
life is thank you better help
[Laughter]
thank you for your help I appreciate it
I mean that
uh I had I never saw these I was in a
supermarket with my cousin on uh the day
before Thanksgiving whatever that
Wednesday is known as okay
uh Thanksgiving Eve I don't know yeah we
went to a we went to a a shop and uh or
Foods place and we just went in to grab
a couple Waters and I found chocolate
covered Ritz crackers oh wow which are a
holiday special edition they're only out
for a limited time they're they're fully
chocolate covered Ritz crackers that
sounds deadly
um I was like this is so weird I I
bought they had one box left I guess
they sell sold pretty well
I bought them because I was like this is
so weird
uh I want to bring it on taste buds and
talk about it I didn't bring them on
I left them you left them I left no I
bought them and I left them
I left them in Jersey I'll leave it at
that
what the [ __ ] happened on Thanksgiving
but sometimes things get tense sometimes
things get tense with the family
uh uh I come from an Italian family it
gets gets heated yeah uh anyway uh but
but I did eat some of them before I left
but uh the uh
they they're really good
okay they're really really good they're
salty and the sweet or yeah I thought it
was weird but then they they taste like
what is that Pocky or Pokey how do you
say that I don't know I never said it
right I just it tastes like those things
yeah it tastes like those things except
except a little saltier because Ritz
crackers have salt on them interesting
they were good they should do it all the
time did you see that new Mountain Dew
flavor they're trying to Rebrand uh
fruit cake as exciting
ugh
there's fruitcake Mountain Dew let me
pull it up there's a new Mountain Dew
there marketing that's supposed to make
the cake your aunt makes you cool
but I mean this is the thing dude it's
hard oh it's even the colors the logo is
the colors of fruitcake it's green and
red and brown
it's terrible
who wants to look at a soda and see
brown like I know Soda itself is brown
like I know Coca-Cola or Pepsi the color
of cola is brown but dude you don't in
the logo
well I guess a and w i i guess yeah root
beer and stuff there's just I guess I
guess a soda that you know for being
like a citrusy flavor when you see brown
in the label it's gross it grows it's
definitely the concept is terrible who's
gonna drink this but then that worries
me is are people in the country drinking
this it's dark red color it's fruitcake
flavor
uh like this just feels like something
they're gonna end up shipping the excess
overseat like I don't know who the [ __ ]
could be it's got predecessors it's not
a first they did a holiday Brew they did
Mary mashup they did gingerbread snapped
and Cobra Cane Mountain Dew for me never
came back from
they never came back from being the
extreme sports drink like I was never a
huge into Mountain Dew what was your
first memory Mountain Dew because it
just existed my whole life that's that
was me too it was like Mountain Dew was
the thing I would get if like they were
out of Sprite
you know what I mean like I'd grab a
Mountain Dew I guess once in a while if
they were out of sprite or something or
like maybe in college I'd grab it here
or there to like mix it as a goof with
vodka or something oh but like oh just
like because in my head I was like oh
that'll be fun and you know whatever but
like it's tough I never drank Mountain
Dew and like I I and like I said it
never came back like one and look it
worked for them branding wise it is the
drink of like remember remember bungee
jumpers yeah yeah yeah yeah it was in
and then Red Bull took it over Mountain
Dew is the drink of snowboarders oh God
snowboarders still think I'm sure it is
I'm sure there's gonna be comments but
shut up how does everyone have no health
care but they're snowboarding yeah so
wait you still go snowboarding snowboard
is like rollerblading is that still a
thing I don't know oh God is it still a
thing I saw a rollerblade Advocate on
Instagram I almost threw up what are we
doing
rollerblading there are certain things
I'm like I don't even know if that still
exists
you know is anyone flying kites that's a
good one man what the [ __ ] I see the
only time I ever see anybody flying a
kite is at the beach and it's once every
six Beach visits yeah it's not even like
every time I go to the beach
they stink it's it's the most boring
even as a kid I was like this bites
there's nothing cool about this and I
didn't think flying a kite was exciting
until I heard the Ben Franklin story
that you could tie a key to it and
lightning would strike it and I was then
I wanted to do that but I wasn't allowed
I wasn't allowed yeah but that's the
only thing about a kite that sounds
interesting to me is that you could like
start like electricity or fire with it
it's kind of cool that's kind of cool
but yeah like there is nothing to me
interesting my favorite store in the
Hamptons was a kite store and their rent
was a hundred grand a month what the
[ __ ] is going on here how much was a
kite like 60 bucks
but they had designer kites there were
some that were like two grand how much
do you think they sold a month I mean
how much could they have possibly done
it was like one of eight stores in the
town I have no idea not a hundred grand
so
I don't know Rich guys just write off
everything if you have a house in the
Hamptons you shouldn't be allowed to
speak in public
dude you should only be allowed to speak
to other people in the Hamptons well
when they come to the city they look at
everyone in the city as below them and
they don't know the secret life of the
Hampton I'm like shut up I mean look
I've I've been to the Hamptons on
vacation before it's a beautiful place
it's fun I could never afford to go
there regular regularly I could never
afford to have a house there uh if let
me rephrase what I just said
if you have a new house if you have a
recently purchased house I don't mean
like they're people that grew up in the
Hamptons when it wasn't worth anything
and they're like dude I help my parents
find a foreclosure there that's the only
reason yeah there are people there that
had houses that that were worth 125 000
they're now worth 3.2 million there's
also a trailer park shout out the
trailer park is where the real people
are that's awesome that's not who we're
talking we're not talking about it think
about if you're one of the people that
buys the house in the Hamptons so you
can go to the kite store yes uh
you shouldn't be allowed to speak in
public
you should only be allowed to talk to
other people in that little desolate
Sandy strip you live on and that's it
they were brutal dude I used to get paid
like five grand to film a woman paddle
board so she could show her nieces oh
God
what the hell do they even talk about
there oh sand
Spurs are bad this year huh well dude I
told you I saw Rudy Giuliani make a
toast at a party I was working and he
said don't worry we're gonna take care
of the sand people and everyone clapped
and I'm like who are the sand people he
means in there he's talking about
Hampton's people right no I know he was
making a statement about the country
really so you think you meant Arab
people which I am one so I can laugh at
the phrase what he means I was confused
I'm on serving shrimp I'm like what I
would be flattered to be called a Sam
person because it would be a Star Wars
reference so even if I was being called
it racially okay uh in derogatory I
would be like ooh Star Wars that would
be you in Star Wars yeah yeah
[Laughter]
now people are going to go you know
that's what Lucas man it was a comment
no it wasn't shut up shut up
poked out Jesus I don't think that guy's
even ever had a beer in his life Lucas
is like
he's you know he was too busy
revolutionizing Hollywood like do you
ever watch that documentary on
industrial Light and Magic it's insane
dude no he created
there are no special effects in modern
Hollywood without George Lucas he
created it it's like insane it's awesome
it's so it's so cool like it's like he's
he's awesome but like I feel like he's a
guy that has no fun like Carrie Fisher
would talk about that she's in her one
woman show she talked about it where she
was like she just said she goes I never
saw him change expression like he just
never like he's so serious all the time
like and she goes now these I guess she
was saying when he was younger now that
he's older I think he's got like a bit
of a sense of humor but I feel like he's
a guy that has never even drank a beer
like he had no time for any foolishness
but it doesn't seem fun though it's
rewarding but I don't know if it seems
funny he created a universe and that's
it you know I mean there's only a few
ways I I interviewed a guy last week I
sent you by accident who did every drug
once yeah yeah and I heard what that was
about I think I'd rather be the sober
guy who worked hard
than the the cracked out dude I think
there's an in-between I don't want to be
either I want to be like the guy that
works like a decent amount but still has
a good time yeah yeah oh God but do you
want to guess uh do you want to guess
what Mountain Dew's name means
uh it's slang for something I would
guess that it's about it's it's it's the
penal discharge of a bunch of of a team
of dirt bikers
that's my best guess slang for moonshine
moonshine
all right so I wasn't that far off
mixing it with vodka it was a booze at
one point that's really gross was
Mountain Dew ever a booze I'm looking
right now
it was made during the Great Depression
um it was originally a mixer for bourbon
all right so see I was spot on pimp yeah
you were you were man there you go all
right and then it became the drink
of parasailing
it says the initial launch of Mountain
Dew was meant as a joke that went wrong
as a joke what year was it launched 46
at the soda convention soda convention
we got to go to Food conventions that's
cool we should do that we should do
really cool get a boot fans what do you
think of this what if we did some and
honestly I want your feedback I really
do
um what do you think if we did some
uh travel apps we'll call them of taste
buds where like you know the whole app
was like we go to uh we go to a food
fair
in New York folks it's the holiday
season let's talk about getting
motivated we all want to lose weight we
all want to get our act together we all
want to do better things for ourself and
it's very hard to do especially during
the holiday season and that's one of the
reasons I love noon num num num they're
a long time sponsor of the podcast they
are a great great company and they do
great great things uh I like that new
weight
uh has a mental health approach to
weight loss uh they are helping you
understand the psychological connection
you have to food your habits why you eat
certain things how to change those
habits Etc
um
I you also find it interesting that Noom
lets you understand why it is better to
eat a certain food over another it's
it's not just you look we all know
obviously it's it's healthier to eat
grapes than a bacon cheeseburger right
but one of the things I learned from
Noom and I've used this example before
is why it's better to eat grapes than
raisins even though both technically are
the same thing and it's because well
grapes have more water you'll get full
more quickly uh and you're gonna you're
gonna ingest less calories less food for
that reason little things like this
little tidbits like this little pieces
of information like this call it trivia
call whatever you want I call it
tools that allow you to take a new
better psychologically based approach to
your weight loss and and your your your
physical Evolution and mental Evolution
we'll call it
uh the app is super easy to use it keeps
you plugged in every day uh you're
you're checking in with the app the
app's checking in with you it keeps you
on top of stuff I I just think it really
works and I think that it's the closest
thing you know a lot of people I know
that uh have made a bit of coin in the
entertainment business have coaches and
and weight loss coaches and and things
like that
I am not somebody that can have
something like that in my life and I
know the average person also isn't Noom
to me is the closest thing you can get
to that uh without the cost of that so I
just think Noom is great uh and it's the
holiday season Now's the Time When
temptation is out there we're busy we're
running around it's hard to tend to
yourself right now let Noom help you do
it so stay focused on what's important
uh you're going to go to noom.com
tastebud singular
tastebudno-m.com tastebud sign up for
your free trial today and check out
noom's first ever book the new mindset
it's a deep dive into psychology of
Behavioral change and that's available
for pre-order wherever books are sold
folks this episode of taste buds is
brought to you by our sponsor betterhelp
better help why do we love better help
here at taste buds well because
betterhelp is helping you get better
it's all in the name it's a good name
when the name tells you what it is
they're they're doing uh better help is
fantastic uh look life doesn't come with
a user manual doesn't come with a
guidebook doesn't come with a way to do
things or a breakdown it just comes with
what it comes with uh and navigating
life's challenges can make you feel
unsure whether it's a career change
whether it's a basic lifestyle change
maybe a relationship change maybe it's
about becoming a parent whatever it is
it's tough better help is here to help
you address uh the the the issues or
problems or or obstacles whatever you
want to call them in life and get to the
place where you were able to start
solving and really uh analyzing and
attacking those things and getting them
into a getting to the core of them
breaking them down fixing them helping
them become manageable all of of this
stuff it's it's I've been somebody who's
been so overwhelmed in life so many
times and I hate it it's terrible it's
it can make you feel isolated better
help is here to get you through that
okay I use better help that's all that's
the best
endorsement I can give you I use it I
love it it has been life-changing for me
they've connected over three million
people with licensed therapists it's
convenient it's accessible anywhere and
it's a hundred percent online
the world's largest therapy service
better help is matched again three
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists a hundred
percent online affordable you go there
you fill out a brief questionnaire to
get matched to a therapist that's it no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist you're
going to learn more and save 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com taste buds
again 10 off your first month when you
go to betterhelp.com taste buds better
h-e-l-p
betterhelp.com taste buds
in fact pimp
having the given the fact that I am a
proprietor yeah of a food place
I actually could get us in and like get
us like elevated access at like the one
on like Pier 17 and stuff hell yeah dude
and like we could go in and and and
shoot and well we should set up a booth
for you try all the different boozes you
should have somebody serve your
sandwiches and we'll set up a podcast
station next to the booth and just film
maybe walk people in yeah that'd be fun
that'd be cool man I really like that
that'd be fun but but also too I'm
curious with the fan thing what about an
episode though where we actually where
it's us just going and interacting with
the people to different booths yeah and
tasting things and you know and talking
food with different vendors why not I
think that'd be fun
all right look we don't have a ton of
time where we at time was here I feel
like we talked for a while here geez
we're like 30-ish minutes all right
let's get to the battle ready yeah
first ever in Texas history folks
a solo battle
a solo battle I want every DeRosa hater
out there to remember this day who was
the one that kept the ship afloat when
nobody was here
yeah pretty soon pimps not even going to
be here it's gonna be me with an iPhone
yeah you'd be talking in the mirror
all right time to
b-a-t-t-l-e buds
cauliflower versus carrots I am team
carrots and I am going to start
by disparaging cauliflower to the best
of my abilities let me re return to my
point earlier stop thinking cauliflower
is a substitute to make everything
healthy every [ __ ] thing people don't
want to have meat in anymore they put
cauliflower in or that they don't want
to have bad carbs in they put
cauliflower I can't eat mashed potatoes
I know what I'll do I'll blend
cauliflower up in a blender and then
I'll have a white paste that smells like
dog and uh and that'll be that'll be in
place of my of my mashed potatoes hey I
I don't want to eat rice because
rice is a simple cut white rice is a
simple carb I know what I'll do I'll
make cauliflower rice and then I have
rice that smells like a dog and then I
and then I by the way it doesn't work
really as rice you know why I've never
seen sushi with cauliflower rice because
number one it would taste like [ __ ] and
number two it won't work it won't it's
cauliflower is rice
in the way that like tofu is a
substitute for chicken or something you
know what I mean you're like yeah I
guess in a saucy dish where the tofu was
gonna take on the flavor of whatever the
[ __ ] Saucy whatever it's mixed in is
it it passes but like well for me you
could never have a you you know what I
mean you could if you had something that
was really like chicken based like like
shredded chicken nachos you could not
use tofu as a chicken substitute or
something you know I mean that to me is
how cauliflower rice works it works in a
sense in place of rice in a dish where
rice is a component but it's secondary
to everything else you can go well it's
you know I dump beef and broccoli on
cauliflower rice yeah it was fine I
couldn't really tell the fine
but if you're eating a true rice dish
like I've tried to do like I've bought
like the Frozen like hey it's it's it's
it's it's it's fried rice except with
cauliflower right it's just it just
doesn't where rice is the focus it
doesn't I don't think it works that's my
opinion yeah I agree with that it's like
buying uh cheap vodka and comparing it
to real you know I mean like it's
Georgie there's something just yeah
there's something just off oh I'll tell
you what the something is the
cauliflower
it's an edible flower I didn't know that
well I guess it's why it's called
cauliflower yeah it's an actual a flower
and the the part we eat is known as the
curd
God it just it what an awful word the
curd the curd I I hate cheese curds too
by the way I I hate the word curd Curtis
says curd has never been a good word
when you when milk curdles it's bad
that's a bad thing like a curd's gross
anyway
uh and then again like like I said
before you take the cauliflower
and you go oh I'll bread it and I'll fry
it and then I'll dip it in blue cheese
instead of hot wings it's like guys
you're probably and I would I would love
to talk to a nutritionist about this
you're probably getting now look if you
don't eat meat you don't eat meat and if
you're going hey I don't care it's not
about it's not about a um
it's not about health it's just about I
don't eat meat because of animals okay
fine that's different God bless do
whatever you're going to do with your
cauliflower but if you're going I do
buffalo cauliflower Wings because I
think it's healthier than chicken wings
I would love to talk to a nutritionist
because I would be willing to bet you
that you're getting more nutrition out
of what's left in that chicken meat than
you are in cauliflower by the time
cauliflower goes through that process
when you saute vegetables when you fry
vegetables all the [ __ ] that's they're
worth that makes them worthwhile leaks
out of it in that pan juice you ready
for the comparison that's why they say
steamed vegetables are the almost or raw
are the two like healthy ways to eat
vegetables yeah once you fry it it's
garbage but it says uh the difference
between cauliflower wings and regular is
they are free of cholesterol and low in
fat and saturated fat and packed with
fiber and antioxidants okay
but chicken is
chicken cholesterol sure has cholesterol
uh it says here with the sauce on it
like a wing sauce cauliflower wings are
450 calories it's the same exact
calories same calories yeah so I don't
know there are dietitians that would
argue that the caloric intake is the
most important thing
there's so many ways you could slice it
like religion
here's my point you know what how about
this how about this vegetarians
you don't want to eat
I'm gonna be a real hypocrite here I'm
gonna be real hypocrite here because I
ate veggie burgers all the time I eat
veggie meatballs last night I'm gonna be
a real hypocrite here
where I draw the line meat on the bone
you want meat on the bone you want a hot
wing and this goes for you boneless
wings people too I can't stand boneless
chicken wings I hate it
get the meat on the bone or don't get it
maybe take that food off your thing you
know and look I'm guilty of it too but
let me digress here for a moment doesn't
anybody just X anything off their list
anymore doesn't even just go you know
what
I chose this lifestyle so I don't get to
have that anymore that's all there is to
it hey folks or this life chose the
Savage life chose me so I don't get to
have that anymore I'm lactose intolerant
I don't get to have milk oh no no no I
still got add milk so let me go get
almond milk hey folks I don't eat meat
anymore so I'm not gonna eat chicken
wings no no no no no hold on we can make
them out of cauliflower you know what I
mean just don't eat it just don't eat x
one of the foods off your list for
Christ's sakes you know what I ordered
that you would hate cauliflower steak
what like what does that even mean it's
just a cheat it's just a piece of color
they cut it like a filet I felt like an
[ __ ] I'm like you just served me
cauliflower for like 35 what it taste
like just whatever sauce they covered in
it just tasted like lumps of nothing
with sauce it's a sauce vehicle
that's the problem too dude with a lot
of like like now that I eat
more plant-based meals than I ever did
that's that's tough dude you got to be
careful a lot of it is so bad for you
because they drench it in this [ __ ] and
sauce went dude I went to a vegan
restaurant once it was one of the best
meals I ever had in my life it was so
bad for you like dude we were eating we
were eating fried bread at one point it
tasted like Kentucky Fried Chicken
so number one it's white bread bad
number two it's fried white bread bad
number three it was seasoned to the
point that it literally tasted like
original recipe KFC chicken it was so
bad for you you know what I mean we're
eating these mushrooms they were amazing
but dude they were covered in bread
crumbs and like well I don't know there
was no cheese and all this stuff it's
like by the time you get to the bottom
of it you're like my God this the only
thing I saved out on here was some
cholesterol and honestly with the frying
of this and the oils I don't know how
much cholesterol I missed out on I don't
know if you know Rick Rubin was fully
that vegan life he gained 250 pounds
from it he did yeah he had to lose all
the weight but dude you pack on weight
with that [ __ ] oil has cholesterol right
yeah
the fans are chiming in like cauliflower
is diverse carrots only do two things
let me tell you what no actually oil
doesn't have cholesterol in it oh really
that's weird yeah I didn't know that
that's that is okay
so the wise oil bad
uh
oil
s can be rich in unsaturated fats
you know so that's the problem yeah a
lot of the fans are chiming that
cauliflower can't stand alone uh but but
but sorry overdoing it on fats and oils
rich in unsaturated fats can contribute
to your saturated fat intake I don't
[ __ ] know it's so people eat whatever
the hell you want I don't even know what
I'm talking about at this point I don't
know if I'm coming or going everything
they tell you they like you said earlier
it's a religion thing yeah they tell you
one thing's healthy there's another guy
in a white coat telling you it's awful
for you then there's another guy with
the mirror thing on his head saying it's
bad that's bad for you I don't know
anymore who the hell no
hell nothing pork spare ribs for
breakfast I don't know what's going on
anymore Joe Rogan eats cheese as far as
I can tell five times a day and he's
incredibly fit I don't know what's
happening
this is why carrots are better than
cauliflower number one carrots have
flavor
number two carrots are in and of
themselves a meal meaning you can take a
whole carrot wash it eat it and it's an
awesome snack you can take that same
carrot dip it in any one of the dips you
like to dip that cauliflower in and
that's great too you cannot you can you
would not ever take [ __ ] chopped
cauliflower and just eat it as a snack
by itself it's disgusting it's
disgusting Also let's talk side dishes
cauliflower on its best goddamn day
couldn't touch
carrots roasted carrots couldn't touch
candied carrots couldn't touch carrots
in brown sugar
okay now I know these things aren't
healthy carrots and brown sugar oh dude
you never had carrots like baked in the
oven with some brown sugar oh my god
dude it's unreal carrots baked with
honey oh dude forget it dude cauliflower
can't touch this [ __ ] I've had
cauliflower carrots one of the Staples
of holiday side dishes too by the way
carrots make their way into Thanksgiving
they make their way at Christmas
whatever
by the way the most popular movie
vegetable of all time the carrot uh uh
anytime anytime you see somebody
chopping vegetables in a movie scene
it's carrots every single time have
never seen somebody chopping cauliflower
the most popular cartoon vegetable of
all time thank you Bugs Bunny very much
carrots
uh
but here's the thing too cauliflower has
only ever made its way to a big meal
uh to the table at a big meal in my
family one way and one way ever
broccoli and cheese that also had
cauliflower incorporated into it okay
outside of that nobody gives a rat ass
about cauliflower nobody nobody and
broccoli has made its way onto the table
many times because you take broccoli and
you prepare it in different ways
broccoli and cheese is just the most fun
and healthy way you can prepare broccoli
but sometimes that casserole in my
family will be made also with
cauliflower included that's it if I if
you brought cauliflower
to my Thanksgiving dinner I swear to god
dude I would SWAT the dish out of your
hand on the front stoop of the house
before you walked in and then I would
say go home
go home
I would let you sit at the table the
dinner table and say racist things
before I would let you break cauliflower
in as a side dish what a host
I would let you be a racist Uncle at the
table before I let you sit there with
cauliflower as a contribution was
cauliflower around in the 80s and 90s
was that yeah oh people were pushing it
like they are now or is it become hip
again because I feel like no no it was
it was it was big cauliflower and
broccoli kale I always thought of them
as the same thing where they were
rebranded no no well I can't speak to
kale I didn't know anything about Kyoto
I lived in L.A uh five six years ago
whatever it was that was where I first
heard like where I first saw kale being
used and everything so kill so
cauliflower was around it's always been
in the background
oh yeah dude cauliflower I'd say was was
pretty big in the 80s and 90s like
cauliflower my mom would make
cauliflower sometimes at dinner time I
know what the fans are going to go
DeRosa and they're gonna put the two
quotes never has cauliflower man next
quote my mom used to me I said big
dinner I said big dinner my mom would
make would have just her me and my dad
she would make cauliflower sometimes
okay it always sucked yeah it sucked
it's it's it sucks oh it just sucks
what's weird is it's cousins with
brussels sprouts which I love
I love brussels sprouts too to an extent
but even brussels sprouts have kind of
run their course for me oh yeah I I I'm
just over it I'm just over it it's it's
there is a
there is a uh
there's just a smell there's a pungent
nature to the Brussels sprout and to
cauliflower that I just can't deal with
as I get older interesting it doesn't
smell appetizing to me when I when
there's leftovers and I try to save them
opening that casserole that you save it
in the next day or or the Tupperware
whatever the next day to re you're like
Ugh like you just get a waft you can't
really eat it yeah no you can't read it
it's just it's like it's like taking
your underwear off after a long sweaty
day
you're just like well oh boy I need a
shower uh it's just gross dude it's
[ __ ] gross man
oh everyone's bringing up the
cauliflower crust pizza that's the new
[ __ ] thing dude read the ingredients
when you go get cauliflower crust at
like Trader Joe's for instance
you read it it's got potato starch in it
it still has white flour it's got all
these other things in it it just has
less of it so if you want to kid
yourself that eating a half cauliflower
crust pizza is what and like look
cauliflower crust pizza yeah it's a nice
it's a nice little substitute but guess
what folks we're not talking about
cauliflower crust pizza we're talking
about [ __ ] cauliflower versus carrots
you hear me sitting here right now
talking about carrot burgers or or any
of the goofy you know carrot I'm not
cigarette carrot cake
[Laughter]
am I talking about carrot cake how about
that though if you want to bring this
other [ __ ] into the mix let's talk about
carrot cake one of the greatest cakes of
all time okay
what is in there cream cheese and cream
cheese icing carrot cake one of the
greatest one of the greatest cakes of
all time Joe I just found the dumbest
thing cauliflower milk
[Laughter]
let's go to the phones pimp I think it's
about that time
oh God I'm just finding a lot of
cauliflower products cauliflower
Cheez-Its
it's disgusting stop it cauliflower
baking mix
that you couldn't tell wow they're doing
they're doing a lot yeah let's go to the
phones um
they're calling uh cauliflower the
albino vegetable
okay Joe shaped like a cauliflower it's
unnecessary
[Laughter]
uh somebody was saying I hope I was
hoping this is a witch's worse
cauliflower overstayed its welcome yes
um
it's confusing how what I really love
eating cauliflower but every time I eat
it I want to gag yeah
that's the thing like I went through
that phase too where I was like wait I
like cauliflower and then I would cook
it I'd be like I don't know if I like
this and then I would get it raw and I
would dip it like in I'd be like oh I
bet this if I put it in some french
onion dip it'll be good and then I'd be
like oh this sucks like it just sucks it
cauliflower it just sucks
there's a t-shirt for you good carrots
are a [ __ ] lie they don't help your
eyesight and refuse to eat a disgusting
vegetable that's also a liar I did
enough of that with my ex-girlfriend
cauliflower
oh wait oh that's a shot against
cauliflower I thought there was
cauliflower all day oh forget that
they're just carrots are just not
disgusting they're just not hey let's
talk carrot sticks A Child's favorite
healthy snack little baby carrots how
cute are little baby carrots put I dare
you to put a bag of baby cauliflower
pieces into a child's lunch and watch
that child run away from home
[Laughter]
that's my closing argument about
cauliflower yeah I mean everyone's
everyone's pretty much turning on
cauliflower
all right all right you ready for the
results do we have a winner do we have a
funny one that we can retweet uh let me
see I like the ex-girlfriend one that's
funny uh um hold on I lost track of it
cauliflower looks like the ghost of
broccoli oh I like that cauliflower
wishes it was broccoli
cauliflower looks like the ghost of
broccoli is very clever it's really good
I like that yeah I love carrots but I
choose cauliflower The Taste Isn't So
dominant in every dish
yeah all right yeah
um the eternal battle between no flavor
and bad flavor
also dude I'm forgetting about like my
God you're every stew carrots
staple staple
carrots by the way you make tomato sauce
or gravy however you call it whatever
your your persuasion is uh in an Italian
thing
what goes in the pan first onions and
chopped carrots or or celery never
cauliflower ever ever
yeah salads you add carrot to salad it's
great you don't add cauliflower to salad
it sucks it sucks
somebody said if you pick cauliflower
you're probably a racist okay
interesting that's funny
uh
see let's give it to uh the ghost one
uh
[Music]
that is Amy hunt Amy hunt 1085. all
right follow Amy all right folks here we
go here we go here we go for plugs check
out the video at the top of the show
and hey you can go watch Steve's special
I guess it's up to you
see
winner with 71 percent
is carrots
that's how I start winning the show
again as I start doing these alone
all right I still love you babe I love
you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to the mic I'm talking